we all have preconceived beliefs about
how we will act behave and communicate
in our personal and professional lives
furthermore we all have shared
aspirations about how we would grow in
our careers and climb the corporate
ladder of success
but somewhere along the way while making
those aspirations a reality we run
across barriers barriers that hold us
from growth
communication skill is one of those
prevalent hurdles
effective communication skills are quite
crucial
they come into play while greeting
people asking or answering questions and
even while writing emails to your
superiors
so today in this video we will go on a
quest to unleash ways to better your
communication skills but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon so you
never miss an update from simply learn
communication is a skill that allows you
to share your thoughts and ideas with
others effectively
most of the time your personality traits
such as attitude and confidence are
judged by the way you communicate with
thorough research we have gathered five
tips that can help you improve your
communication abilities
moving forward we will iterate through
them one by one
the first tip on our list is be a master
listener wait you must be thinking what
does listening have to do with
communication well let me tell you
listening is quite essential to build a
rapport with the people you are
interacting with not only that but it
also serves as a means of displaying
respect for others
consider how good it feels when someone
is intently listening to you and is
absolutely intrigued by what you are
saying
don't you feel valued and obligated to
forge ties with that person you do right
so make sure that you don't go on a
monologue while having a chat with
someone
be comfortable and patient under your
skin and try to comprehend all
non-verbal cues
also strive to emphasize key topics or
words from the discourse
this will help you recall the
conversation afterward and will
demonstrate to the speaker that you are
paying attention
the next tip we have is to be aware of
your body language people will take
clues from your body language so be
mindful of how you portray yourself
while speaking with someone in person or
via a virtual call
it's always a good idea to record
yourself and study how others view you
take note of how you stand or sit how
you move your arms and your hands
how your body is oriented and how your
facial expressions are
you can also ask for help from your
friends or family to examine your body
language
after a thorough analysis you can
highlight your blunders and work on them
with plenty of practice you'll be able
to align your body language with your
spoken one the third tip on our list is
to be tactful
being tactful is also an essential
aspect of being a good communicator
people will be even receptive to hear
information they are already familiar
with if it's presented in a diplomatic
matter
a good communicator can predict how
someone would react and adjust their
statements at any instance based on the
listener's reaction but for that to
happen you'll have to understand your
listener take non-verbal cues from his
actions and contemplate a way to
understand his interest
you will also need to manage your
emotional quotient being emotionally
stable might assist you in bringing
clarity of thought to each point you
make in a discussion on that note can
you all mention the greatest challenge
you have faced while having an official
interaction
make sure you drop your answers in the
comments section below
the next and quite important tip when it
comes to formal communication
is to be brief and to the point
whether you're talking to a person or
writing a mail to someone make sure to
use simple language and keep your
sentences short and concise being
concise is the finest way of acquiring
clarity
it can help you deliver values through a
minimum number of words and can also
help others understand your point
you can achieve that by understanding
the core points you want to convey and
composing a few short and crisp
sentences to describe it
also ensure that you refrain from using
any filler words one way to do that is
to keep a track of every time you use
the words like or
um
by being conscious of the words you use
you can withhold filler words or
informal phrases
the last tip on our list is practice
more there is a famous saying that
practice makes you perfect
and if you are to apply that in the
sense of articulation then not only
should you read but you should also
write down your thoughts
doing these two tasks for 30 minutes
daily can help you straighten out your
thoughts
also to become an effective leader
you're expected to possess enormous
knowledge
reading listening and writing are the
facets that can help you get there
once you develop competence in verbal
skills the next phase will be putting
them to use when you converse
joining public speaking clubs or events
on your campus can help you boost your
confidence
we know that confidence comes from
within so your body language fluency and
persona will contribute to your
communication skills when you are
confident enough here's a video that can
help you figure out how you can build
your confidence
that's all we have for today i hope
these five tips will assist you in your
pursuit of excellence in terms of
communication skills thank you for
watching the video and stay tuned for
more from simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn nerd up and get certified
click here